[Music]
the history of the world is the history
of violence mankind seems intent on
destroying itself but there is an
artifact
known as the apple of Eden with it any
impulse towards independence or
rebellion will be crushed
we've traced the protectors of the
artifact all the bloodlines have died
out bar one
his name's Callum Lynch I'm doctor Sofia
RIKEN I'm here to help you and you are
here to help me how are you people with
their everything about you come we've
been looking for something and we need
you to get it for us
you're about to enter the Animus what
you're about to see hear and feel are
the memories of your ancestor who's been
dead for 500 years what are you for me
your past wait a minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
what I saw in there
it felt real it was you give them the
Apple and they win the Templars will use
it to destroy us with now pioneer we
fight
I'm beginning to like that
you are destined for great things that's
fine now
we work in the DAR just sort of the
light we are assassins second chance
[Music]
what do you want from me your past